hey hey it's your girl Anitra I'm Selena
has titties I'm princess poppy I'm
Malaysia baby doll baby doll baby doll
I'm Sasha Colby I'm Lux Noir London hey
sis it's amethyst hi it's Marsha Marsha
Marsha hi I'm spice I think hi it's the
queen of Queens Jax I'm Irene the alien
Dubois good evening ladies and gentlemen
mistress is about
Brooke hi it's sugar and I'm your dad's
worst nightmare hello it's your Filipino
Moon Goddess oromayari hi I'm Robin
thierson That's Robin with an eye not a
y I'm Lucy laduka and I have nothing
cute to say the taglines are out of
control
with the cast of RuPaul's Drag Race
season 15 and we're here at busty to
play a game of Who's Who
foreign
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
like I've been telling everyone like I
came here today at BuzzFeed I was like
good morning I hope you're having a
blessed day I wish the best for everyone
this is how I get treated so [ __ ] the
first thing you told us was we didn't
have hot water
mistress being congenial is like me and
my top ever like
[Applause]
honestly half the cast
me
I'm the youngest but I'm the most
culture in here yeah
we we are a season of beautiful smooth
brain dum-dums
who would have gotten the old
you know Aura and I are the same age
five six seven eight you ready
[Music]
they've never been already on time in
their life she's not even supposed to be
here right now
I don't know what everyone's talking
about
honestly we got it down to like three
hours instead of four so it's like
progress that's just the lashes yeah
[Music]
oh yeah
I would give you a front-handed insult
me there can I be people not in this
room
[Applause]
okay Robin Robin's that girl who would
say something
yeah
wow you're really Blended today
what's today I object I object I think
Robin would never give a backhand a
compliment I mean not Opera she would
just never give a compliment right I
mean that's if we're talking about you
oh wow exhibit a [ __ ]
hahaha
[Music]
or Aurora oh my god um
I mean I think our cats in general has
been getting a lot of attention for our
out of drag appearances I got no nudes
in my DMs yet I think I think Lucy's a
trade
I'm a construction worker
that's pretty tight but I do sound like
a woman so it kind of
um
you know they really have been through
so much I mean I don't know about a Duo
but I do know about a trio
[Music]
[Laughter]
me a little bit sure why not Selena who
I feel like this is really a lip syncing
season yeah yeah I need one of these
[ __ ]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
[Music]
Miss Lucy Goose
yeah
she finishes first yes
I'm done with my makeup about an hour
before everybody else so I just I've got
time yeah it's a little about to fall I
don't even try to go fast everybody else
just paints really slow yeah
behind me with nails yeah
what
well I would say I mean I don't know
about sell it but
it's on a date oh that's my favorite
line from drag race when Gia gun does
her hot glue yeah she said these other
girls think they're giving Couture but
they're really giving hot glue like we
literally walk around our house and I
just go yeah oh yeah yeah oh my God the
details of this season
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and make sure you catch RuPaul's Drag
Race season 15 only on MTV
thank you